i want to show you how to completely
stop acid reflux once and for all
i had acid reflux really bad in college
i was downing massive amounts of tums
not having a clue of what caused it i
really wish i knew back then what i know
now because it would have been so easy
to correct i mean just months and months
of suffering this terrible heartburn i'd
have to kind of sit up like propped up
in my bed to try to have it drain
because at night it would be terrible so
what is acid reflux it's a situation
where you're having acid that's
regurgitating coming up
through a valve
into the esophagus and that valve is
called the lower esophageal sphincter
now the most important thing to know
about acid reflux
is that it's caused by
not enough acid okay there's a
deficiency of acid in your stomach
and that acid is not
triggering a certain mechanism to close
the valve
at the top of the stomach at the bottom
of the esophagus and then the valve
doesn't close and so the acid
regurgitates so the term for this low
acid situation is called
hypochlorhydria that is the root cause
of your heartburn so that means low
stomach acid there's another condition
called a chlorhydria which there's no
acid in your stomach okay and that
happens with people
as they get older and older in fact as
we age we lose
the acid in our stomach and we have all
sorts of digestive problems 30 of the
population over the age of 60 has a
deficiency of stomach acid so it's a big
deal so what happens is we get on
antacids
we take
medication to
deal with this and then of course the
side effects from that are horrendous
because we're doing the exact opposite
of what we should be doing so it makes
us feel better temporarily but the next
time we eat
it gets worse and worse and worse and we
never come off this medication
it is so important
to ensure
that our stomach has the right ph and
the normal ph of the stomach
should be between one and three that is
extremely acid okay so on the ph scale
you have seven being neutral and so if
it goes up like eight nine ten that's
more alkaline as it goes below seven
that is more acid in each whole number
that you go down it's by a factor of 10x
so in other words a ph of 5 is 10 times
more acid than a ph of six okay so if
we're talking about
a ph of one to three that is extremely
acidic and that's what you really need
to break down proteins to absorb
minerals and vitamins like b12 and folic
acid and vitamin c
and also
another reason why we need it is to kill
off
microbes fungus bacteria to prevent
those microbes from growing in our small
intestine the key thing about the
stomach
as far as the release of that acid
and the closing of that valve is that
there's a link between the two in other
words
that valve normally should close
if there's enough of a certain chemical
called gastrin that
causes the release of hydrochloric acid
so this is communication from the level
of acid
to the valve
and that the closing and opening of the
valve and this whole thing is under
parasympathetic control now what does
that mean it's under um
the part of the nervous system
that controls
digestion and
rest
okay
so that opposes the other system that's
called the sympathetic which is the
flight of fight so what does that mean
the more stress that you have the more
acid reflex you're going to have to
because as you increase the sympathetics
you decrease the parasympathetic so
stress is another reason why we have a
lot of problems with the stomach and the
reason why we might have acid reflux or
another term for that would be gerd now
there's some other importances
of having the right amount of acid and
i'm talking about hydrochloric acid
hydrochloric acid also helps you release
bile from your gallbladder it helps to
cause the gallbladder to contract and
release the bile to help you
extract fat soluble vitamins from your
food
as well as omega-3 fatty acids and help
you break down fats
also this hydrochloric acid helps
stimulate the pancreas to produce
enzymes to help you digest food so
without that acid being
at the right ph you're not going to have
sufficient bile release and you're not
going to have sufficient enzymes
released and that's going to cause
a lot of other problems a little bit
lower down in this chain reaction
and then what happens is you might have
bacteria
and fungus that then grows in the small
intestine
and that's called
sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
and then every time you you just feel
bloated you feel distended and this will
definitely occur if you're eating fiber
and probiotics so
yeah that's a that's a situation also
one last thing about hydrochloric acid
you need the correct ph of the stomach
to keep h pylori in check
normally our bodies have h pylori and
it's not creating any problem for us but
when we lose the stomach acid
then it comes out and it creates
problems so this is just another
important reason why we need
this hcl hydrochloric acid in our
stomach the other thing that can mess us
up in relationship to not having enough
hydrochloric acid is
low zinc which is very common for so
many people if you're low in zinc you'll
have a tendency to have problems with
gerd as well as acid reflux as well as
ulcers
so
it takes a sufficient amount of zinc to
make hydrochloric acid it also takes
other things like chlorides
as in sodium chloride like salt to make
hydrochloric acid it also takes a good
amount of potassium to make hydrochloric
acid so it might be your problem is
really coming from a
zinc deficiency maybe a chloride
deficiency or even a potassium
deficiency so it's not just about taking
hydrochloric acid it's about taking the
raw materials that can actually build up
your your acid now another thing that a
lot of doctors do not
have any information about is the
connection between
taking calcium and having too much
calcium and having acid reflux or gerd
so one of the big side effects of taking
a calcium antacid is
acid
reflux it's completely
insane and the problem is if you don't
understand a connection you could be
giving someone the absolute worst thing
to give them for that condition so if
you're going to your
doctor
for this condition definitely tell them
to research the link between
hypercalcemia and gerd or acid reflux
now people don't just take calcium
antacids they take other
types of medication for acid reflux like
ppis for example and the problem with
those medications is that there's some
massive side effects like inflammation
your kidney nephritis like getting
fractures from osteoporosis
getting other
pathogens like c diff so there are a lot
of side effects from these antacids all
right so here's the plan this is what i
recommend
the best remedy for this is to take
something to build up your hydrochloric
acid and that's called betaine
hydrochloride and this is how you take
it
you start off taking like three right
before a meal see how you feel okay
let's say you still have a problem but
it's better
next meal
take four
take five before a meal and you keep
increasing it
until your symptoms go away and it could
take
seven eight or more of these
little petaine hydrochloride tablets
before you have no more
acid reflux now all this means is that
you're very deficient in this acid and
you have to build it back up and it does
take time i would also recommend this so
let's say for example you're up to eight
betaine hydrochloride okay and your acid
reflux goes away and you feel great
i would continue to take a little bit
more
until
you start getting
kind of like a maybe a heartburn or a
warmness in your stomach which means
you've taken too much so then you can
back off
that way you can know exactly how much
you really need
to fix this problem number two make sure
you're getting enough potassium and sea
salt in the diet because
those are the the precursors to building
hydrochloric acid number three i would
make sure you're getting sufficient zinc
which is also very important in this
process and number four chew your food
longer okay that's going to
assist this whole process especially
right now if you don't have enough
hydrochloric acid in your stomach um you
just need to chew more and that's going
to help this process and make everything
go a little bit faster and number five
make sure you keep your stress down
because
uh stress could be aggravating the
situation um we don't want you to be in
a sympathetic dominant mode we want you
to be in the parasympathetic where
you're relaxed
so you really want to put your body in a
relaxed state when you eat because it's
going to help your digestion now on that
note i have another really
good video that explains
the entire digestive process okay
starting from the stomach going all the
way down to the large intestine that's a
really good video you should watch that
next and i put that video up right here
check it out
you